okay great so i guess we have an hour
um i'll talk for about 15 minutes i
guess
uh plus um and then we have some time
for
for discussion um so
um for those of you who don't know me
which is probably most of you
um i'm a professor of computer science
at georgia tech
i've taught a couple of moocs both
in networking but on slightly different
topics and i'll talk about
each of those experiences here i think
this should be fairly controversial
because i have strong opinions but i
actually don't know what i'm talking
about
so so away we go um i speak from
experience
uh not not from principle here so um in
the past year i've taught
uh taught two different moocs i've
taught both of them a couple times now
um one was a free
mooc on a topic called software defined
networking i'll
i'll explain to you in a minute what
that is just very briefly
that course has something like it's been
taught twice each time it's been taught
to um about 50 000 students enrolled
each time about
uh 4 000 plus students end up sort of
completing all the assignments
um i'll talk more about the numbers in
that
later the other uh
mooc that i'm gonna put in quotes uh
is uh this udacity uh mooc that uh that
i've
basically taught as part of the computer
networking
uh well it's a computer networking
course as part of georgia tech's online
master's program which
you may have read about it it was like
on a1
in the new york times a while ago um so
um okay so what i'm going to talk about
is
is a little bit of my experience
teaching both of these moocs the first
one i found to be
uh the corsair one very pleasant
very scalable uh very shoestring
lightweight low budget etc and the
second actually to be
pretty much uh anything but any of those
some of the reasons there i think are
implementation based some of them i
think are
potentially fundamental and maybe that's
what we'll spend
you know the rest of the hour talking
about okay so
i'm going to talk a little most of the
time i'm going to talk about
um sort of my ex well i'm going to talk
a little bit about my experience with
both so
first of all what is this first mooc and
and you know i'm not going to belabor
the technical details here
but um the reason that i'm explaining to
you a little bit about like technically
what it's about is because it's
important for
for like the rest of our discussion is
that it's a very focused
topic this is sort of like a you know
second level graduate course topic it's
very niche
it's sort of a hot topic right now it's
also
extremely hot in industry so as we look
at the demographics of people taking the
course it's it's kind of interesting as
well
um but it appeals to basically
professionals people who are like
at cisco who've been working as network
operators for 20 years
and they're like hey what's this new
thing let me go check it out
so i'll talk a little bit about that in
a little more detail but
you know for example there were study
groups of like you know 30 and 40 people
from att
taking the course you know people in
their 40s and 50s
who are who are trying to figure out
what the
the latest new thing is i've had two
offerings
last summer i taught it uh there was a
six week version
this was very much like i was almost i
was like putting it together like just
ahead of like
offering it um and then this this summer
i basically filled in a lot of the gaps
actually this topic unlike probably um a
lot of topics that we teach
is like a super moving target because it
actually wasn't even a real topic
like three or four years ago and and
things that are basically
um going on now will end up in the
course like in a year so
it's it's a serious moving target
there's there's no really good book
even for example um who takes it um
as i mentioned there are about 50 000
people who who like hit the enroll
button but as we know that that means
various things
there's something like 10 000 people who
like are actively watching videos on any
given in any given week
i'm sorry active doing something you
know anywhere between like one and three
thousand like watching all of the
lectures
um something like 3 500 this year like
watched you know
you know basically made their way
through the whole course and then um
something like 500 plus turn in
programming assignments
in any given year i think this year oops
i better keep this
this year um there's something like
maybe 800 who who attempted all their
like eight programming assignments one a
week so it's pretty intensive
and i'll talk about i'll talk a little
bit about that as well and how we made
that scale
but that's interesting here too because
a lot of people taking the course
actually aren't used to programming
they're network operators
right not computer scientists so they're
like what's this python thing like i've
been doing cisco for 20 years
other demographics so like
lots of people from the us in this
particular offering
and then you know here's another i
thought this was sort of interesting too
a lot of them employed full-time so
that's going to kind of come back
as well in some of uh when i talk about
demographics and and
and the differences in the experiences
as well um
uh okay so you've probably seen this
kind of thing i don't need to get into
that
this is of course with the students see
this is if anyone has done anything on
coursera this will look super familiar
if you've done something in similar
platforms
probably looks familiar but actually
having done something in udacity
it's if the only thing you've seen is
udacity this probably looks foreign and
actually that's why the slide is here
basically having a super lightweight
mechanism
for adding course content that
i can use right as opposed to like a
production staff
has proved to be highly highly useful
right the ability for me to go in there
like
after something has been assigned and
tweak a due date or tweak visibility or
add something or fix a bug without going
through a staff
is immensely useful useful or record a
lecture at three in the morning
in pajama bottoms just kidding
so so how was the course developed so
i'll contrast this with the other course
as well um
you know um this was interesting to me
as well like um
course lesson plan with learning
objectives the first actually so a lot
of people here i guess are learning
people the first time i heard the term
learning objective was when i taught a
mooc i've been lecturing for like six or
seven years
uh before that i was like what's a
learning objective um
so one of the things this is not what
this talk is about but one of the things
i took away was
was that oh this mooc thing is really
interesting like even if it doesn't
actually
you know take off which clearly it is
but it's you know aside you know putting
aside all the hype it's actually
really changed the way i think about in
classroom teaching
as well so there's a whole nother talk
or discussion on that
because actually uh wow administration
is paying attention to it like
uh that's interesting now i need to
learn how to teach
okay so top-down design right and then
so the production so i'll talk a little
bit about the production and this is
where things start to diverge in the two
moocs right
so um and in fact this is where
sort of i realized like um i had a lot
to learn and i think also the people who
are like designing
uh moocs uh or telling people how to do
them
probably could stand to learn a few
things too so we started doing this like
in a studio at georgia tech like you
know schedule studio time
blah blah blah blah this was just like
totally intractable
um i actually found that a studio so
i've actually done like
tv interviews right i've which is its
own weird thing right like you sit in
some newsroom and like you're talking to
someone
it's pretty disorienting i found this to
be like a thousand times more
distracting because there's this dude
like
on the side like in your peripheral like
i just couldn't do it
um so and there were like a lot of
people watching right the studio time is
limited
um i actually didn't like the
post-production quality i had very
little control over it and i guess
coming back to the second course i'll
talk about that a little bit more
um and i just found that as a faculty
member like you know a lot of people
you know may you know teaching might be
their first order of business but for me
it's like my third order of business so
i needed to basically fit this in when i
could fit it in and this just like
didn't work so
i quickly scrapped that and started
using camtasia right so now
um this was sort of um controversial
i think uh the studio people at georgia
tech like i think actually
um that you know they're trying to
basically justify their employment
because they're like okay well you know
the quality of your videos is gonna
really suffer
like if you don't use the studio and
blah blah you must use it
and i agree like you know the quality of
my videos
is probably worse um than
a production quality studio video
however
um no one ever complained like of all
the people watching the videos
no one said boy it's a little like
buzzing in the background or
boy you're you're looking down at this
it was people were
were you know when they had comments on
the videos it was all about content
right um so and i just found this
infinitely easier to do
it takes a little getting used to of
course and also
at least in my case i did all of my own
editing
which is which is a plus and a minus so
the minus of course is it just takes
more time
the pluses though i found is that i'm
more engaged in the content like i'm
more engaged
in in the course and actually i got
quite fast at it like i got to the point
where i could look at audio waveforms
and just like cut like figure out where
i'd done a retake and cut it out
um this is sort of like basically um
you know uh how the the rule of thumb
that that it you know that it took for
me
um you know in terms of like producing
you know um i think um
uh one of the one of the biggest lessons
i found is that like actually editing
can be quite easy to do on your own you
can do it on a pretty pretty much a
shoestring
uh you know shoestring operation you
don't need like a massive editing staff
because often we're just speaking right
and
if you mess something up speaking it's
easy enough to do a retake
and cutting is probably like the easiest
thing to edit um
so i got very very fast actually these
numbers i think
uh like 10 to 15 minutes of lecture for
like two hours
of recording and editing that was like
when i did it the first time i'm now
down to like i can do it in about an
hour
like something of that time so you get
pretty good at it but it actually also
starts to be pretty fun
um because you're because you're
creating something
um okay so like okay this is basically
the
the the sort of plan that i took in my
production process
um um probably don't need to like get
into all of this
now um one of the things um that that
sort of as i sort of like took ownership
over creation of the lecture content
i started to think about like new ways
to to to give lectures
and one of them actually was like
on-screen demos
right so um you know this is one thing
that i just never would have thought of
like
in a studio setting but i was like oh
i'm doing like this camtasia stuff i'm
doing a you know screen capture
i want to show something in code like i
want to show a demo why don't i just do
a screen capture of like what's on my
laptop and just like you know basically
splice that into the video turns out you
know
okay maybe obvious but as it turns out
like when i was wanting to do that with
udacity and
the online masters it just like was not
the barriers were too high for that
the other thing that i was that i
thought about doing was basically well
why not
people talk about in moocs like oh we'll
just have like the expert on that topic
like give the course and then we don't
need to have physics 101 taught by 100
people like we can just have the best
person do right well
i thought well you know who's to say
that i'm the best person to teach this
why don't i bring in some other people
to actually talk so
i basically just started using google
on-air hangouts to like bring in other
people like and i basically
was the uh um you know um
you know basically just interviewing
them like for for uh questions and
content and i thought
um i you know that was something that i
just never would have thought of had i
not like had total ownership over
like the creation and production of the
material um and then since then like
lots and lots of people who are doing
moocs and
other things have just copied the idea
so i think the lessons like that i
learned from this like first
crack was you know i didn't you know
lots of money like
was not needed in this case now of
course if you count the cost of my time
and the cost of like the ta time
so it's not free although no one paid me
to do it
um but you know my time certainly is
worth something
it's only i guess you can say it's only
free if your time has no value right
um so but um but you can do this on a
pretty
on a pretty shoe on a shoestring kind of
uh budget
i think the other thing too is is that
um
one of the things that i found um is
that
the moocs themselves are kind of
asynchronous right like the students can
consume
the content kind of like at their own
pace like at their own time they don't
have to like show up at the lecture at a
certain time
and that's a you know you know that
provides some advantages for them
now on the flip side like you know as
lecturers
we can benefit from the same thing like
you know um
the fact that i can do the lecture when
i'm feeling like in the zone and like
wanting to basically record a lecture
um you know i should be able to take
advantage of that
when i have to go into a studio to do
that it kind of like takes away
and i have to sit down for three four
hours and start recording lectures it
kind of takes away some of that
um some of that being in the zone um
assignments so like scaling right so i'm
going to talk now a little bit about
other parts of the course in production
so scaling
and this is one thing again where things
when i draw some contrast
at the end i think
things basically there's a lot there's a
bit to learn here so
even the even the platform i would say
like the the coursera platform that we
use
um for the sdn course um is not
super good at handling things that are
not multiple choice this is something i
think i would love to see and you know
maybe there are other platforms that are
better at this
but you know things like oh we wanted to
have a short answer where you could have
like any one of these three things would
give you like points and they're like oh
no problem just write this regular
expression i've cut it off here but it's
like
you know 10 line regular expressions
it's like great i need to
you know i need to you know to go review
my programming languages
to uh to basically write the solutions
to this quiz so
um basically what what ended up
happening there is basically
just simplify um and i think
um you know perhaps there are things
like pedagogically i think where
you know perhaps the students might be
getting more if they had other ways to
sort of fill in answers
one of the things that i found is that
like uh writing the explanations for
different
options like uh has sort of helped plug
that hole
um but but certainly there's there's uh
there's
you know this is a corner that we've cut
for scaling
where uh there's a trade-off the
assignments
actually are tricky right so this is a
pretty as i mentioned a programming
intensive course
we wanted to to teach like concepts with
hands-on
and we wanted also people writing code
the grading actually needs to be done
like
on a highly scalable fashion as well
right so we can't be reading we can't be
running everyone's code
or debugging it right so basically what
we did is we designed
all of the assignments to um to
basically run
in a particular execution environment
and then we'd grade the output like
based on regular expressions that we
picked that the students didn't know
um so to give yeah to basically explain
this a little bit more and this is
actually something where
i think um in the second course i taught
we have
really not figured out auto grading and
this is one of the huge impediments to
scaling
but like one of the ways that we achieve
this is basically
make sure well encourage or
to the extent we can control it ensure
that people are running the same
program the same operating environment
so the way that we've done this
is we've built a virtual machine right
with a common
operating system set of packages
installed blah blah blah blah and we say
download this virtual machine we have
to the extent possible try to keep it
small because
as we know like in certain countries the
cost of data
is is prohibitive so we've tried to
basically keep it small
now what we have found uh you know
another sort of like we've tried to
basically do this
to limit our pain in terms of like
scaling technical support and debugging
what we've found is that people
basically just do their own thing anyway
and a lot of times when you
because of the way that we've designed
like designed the assignments to have
people
run things in this operating environment
spit out some output send it to a
grading server
right there are things that actually are
performance dependent like okay
we're running network performance
between like two nodes in inside a
virtual environment and
you know it works in the environment
that we've tested but now someone
basically has installed their own thing
and it doesn't work and you know we
basically get five
questions into trying to help them out
when we realize they're not running the
course virtual machine
right so this is one of the things that
has basically helped us scale
and to the extent that people follow
directions
we can continue scaling forums i think
is another place where
basically this was a huge surprise to me
i was like god how am i going to
contribute like
you know communicate with 10 000
students now this
i would say can scale okay and then this
is something where
um where basically um
this depends i think the the ability for
for
i mean sort of the the ability for this
to scale
depends a bit on the demographics of the
students and their motivation
right this scales very well in the in
the free course
of 50 000 students and actually does
scale it all
in the four credit paid course of 200
students
why well in this course in in the sort
of free course
with the you know niche topic i have
highly motivated students there for
their own enrichment wanting to
basically learn of highly specialized
topic
not there for a degree or credit and not
paying therefore
willing to put in the extra effort to
grind through you know things that you
know
aren't you know working the first time
willing to help other students out often
by the time
you know i see a question that's already
been answered take that to the other
uh to the other
operating environment where we have
students who are basically
taking a general purpose networking
course
may not be interested in the topic
interested in a degree but maybe not
interested in networking
paying for it therefore expecting
interaction
with course staff and this is basically
a case where
the two experiences could not have been
more widely divergent
like you'd never think that it'd be
easier to manage a form of 50 000 than a
form of 200 but in this case
um it has been um so basically
um this is a little bit more on that
right so why like assignments and
and some of the in and some of these
things can scale um
so one of the things is is uh you know
when i give something out to 50 000
people are
you know in you know people who are
actually looking at it four thousand
still a lot of people
um i don't actually know who's out there
right um
some of those people may be uh you know
highly famous
or highly important people and i don't
they're faceless and there are a lot
of them right so i do a lot of you know
a lot more work
on these assignments before i release
them mostly out of fear because i don't
want to actually make a fool of myself
when there's a mistake
and if there's a mistake instantly i get
you know hundreds of people
saying there's a mistake but more
importantly than that
in this in this first course um you know
in
in the in the in the in the sdn course
there's self-selection
right everyone who's basically doing the
assignments wants to be there and i
actually
cranked that up one more notch in the
second offering
i offered two tracks i said okay
basically there's a programming track
and a non-programming track if you want
to do the programming track you get the
distinction certificate otherwise you
know don't do the programming track so
even more we have people who are
basically they just want to be there
and they often as a result fix things
themselves and they rewrite
documentation so i've actually had cases
where
i mean here's basically an example of
like there was one thing i left out of a
video in terms of like setup
and someone was like oh you left this
out like here's a blog post on like
basically how to do this properly it's
like thanks
i just rolled it into the course
material so now it's there
one idea that basically now i'm going to
use i'm going to try to use the next
time around
that i got that i got from someone else
is take the best students here
and there are a lot of people who are
basically motivated to btas like
community tas so i'm going to basically
try that next time it seems like
based on the level of engagement of some
of these students that should work
people liked it okay so moving on
so the second mooc this is much shorter
actually
because i'm mainly just drawing contrast
um
so mook um so there's something like 120
students
in each offering uh so far of i've
taught this now twice
um i'm going to put tot like this as
well
for reasons that we can we can discuss
but this is just like a
it's like night and day um so the
in the abstract that i submitted and
this is supposed to be the technical
track right there are actually i found
to be huge technical differences between
the platforms
uh that actually kind of like affect uh
both delivery and pedagogy
everything ranging from like you know is
this going to scale to just my general
level of engagement
um so let me just draw a few contrast so
how is this course developed okay
similar top down planning
but actually um they wanted scripts
ahead of time right so
as opposed to like you know me basically
recording a video
uh or a set of videos a week ahead of
time posting a week at a time
it was like script out the entire course
like
you know script out the entire 15 weeks
ahead of time before you even head into
the studio
which i found incredibly hard to do and
i think actually the other
other folks shared my my uh my my uh
frustration with that challenge um now
okay
on the other course right it was
basically me
a ta basically ta who was one of my phd
students
who just basically wanted to learn the
topic who was who's helping out
for free as well in this case we had
several full-time staff members so this
is like mythical man month right
a course developer who is super useful
as it turns out
then a video editor who is useful in the
sense that i didn't have to edit my own
videos
but that's a double-edged sword i think
because all of a sudden i'm basically
one step removed from creation of the
content and that's
that's that's uh that's created its own
set of issues which we can talk about
um then part-time people right
pay tas graders etc right so no sort of
investment in
in like auto grading and scaling up
front so now there's this sort of
self-perpetuating thing where i would
say
everybody's happy right because um
people in in some well everybody's
reasonably happy because there's money
coming in
right people are getting paid i'm
getting paid the tas are getting paid
um and there's a there's a machine uh
uh full of people who are basically um
you know going through the motions but
making no effort to basically scale
things up right so
why do we need to kind of invest time in
auto grading if we have paid tas and
graders so there's just sort of like
that stuff isn't isn't happening um
the course was recorded in studio ahead
of time with custom equipment right so
this was
this was interesting i probably i
recorded the whole course
maybe in uh uh 10 or 15 like
you know set like sit-down sessions of
like three to six hours each
right and me scribbling on a tablet
having no idea what the
the final output would look like because
i would just basically scribble and then
say
oh wait i messed that up and then sort
of go through and then some weeks later
i would kind of see what the
the final video looked like and
oftentimes i didn't like it but it was
like
i'm out of the zone i'm like and
actually i should say a few times
there have been mistakes and actually
i've got a i've got a list i've got like
a document
of of things i need to go and fix in the
sort of do-it-yourself mode i've i've
fixed everything like often like
like in the same week that it's been
offered because something gets posted in
the form they're like hey there's a bug
i'm like cool
i'll just pop open camtasia re-edit that
like
throw on the same shirt if i need to but
like re-edit that right put it up
and in this case it's like oh man i
gotta go to the studio like okay i got
to schedule the time i'm not in town oh
wait i'm teaching
like okay forget it like i've got now
it's been six months and i've got like
three or four likes pretty minor bugs
that just like
you know haven't been fixed um the other
thing is like all the stuff that i found
that was really
interesting like sort of like got me
thinking about pedagogy like oh
on-screen demos like that would be
really interesting or oh like let's do
some interviews with luminaries like
it just be the sort of the mode of
scribbling on a tablet
um in a studio it just like
it doesn't lend itself to the same kind
of delivery and and um
i think basically i'll come back to that
point in like when i wrap up here
um and and then initially all the
material was released at once um i think
there was something in the keynote about
this as well like i couldn't figure out
what the verdict was
i'm not i'm not a learning expert but
here's a place where i don't know what
i'm talking about i'm gonna offer my
opinion this is a huge mistake
as far as i as far as i'm concerned like
and i'll talk about why in a minute
um in the coursera course i did i
released stuff one week at a time
much better okay so just some
comparisons um
video delivery we've talked about
grading i've talked about
right uh the forums like um initially
the coursera stuff i used homebrew like
i moved to piazza actually a lot of
coursera students
complained at first because they're used
to you know they take another coursera
courses they're like
what's this piazza thing um but they got
used to it
um and actually they stopped complaining
as soon as they realized that i was
answering their questions um
um the pacing i just mentioned i'll talk
a little bit more about that
um the demographics hugely different
right
um the cost um again these are just sort
of like this is here just to be
provocative this is not like i didn't
tabulate anything i just sort of like
you know um back of the envelope just
thought about it um
hugely different in terms of like cost
of production
i don't know so now i'm just trying to
be a little controversial in a couple
closing slides right so
um substance trump style okay like when
when
i said okay forget it with this studio
i'm just gonna like do it all in
camtasia
you know people were like a huge mistake
like you know
videos are going to look crappy like you
know people aren't going to like it when
you know your bedroom is in the back or
whatever
people actually don't seem to care as
far as i can tell like
the main complaints i get are on on
content like or
to the extent that we get complaints
like it's more like things being unclear
this or that right
um uh i think
um there are different modes that work
for different
um types of material right so for some
like
a you know handwritten tablet might be
the best delivery
uh mechanism for others you know
maybe not um but it seems that there are
certain platforms that that sort of
dictate the the mode of delivery and i
just don't think that's that's
right um okay so
another um sort of point here so this
isn't this is provocative by the way my
dean has seen my position statement as
well i thought he would be
um you know i thought he'd be more upset
than he was when i when i showed it to
him but um
i've sort of used it as an opportunity
to offer some constructive feedback so
because like the i think the the the
vision of course is to sort of scale
that degree in my opinion there is that
basically
the way that it's currently running is
is not well suited to scaling um and
particularly not
well suited to quality scaling i mean
some of those reasons are technical and
some of them are may not be right so
one of the things that that allows a
mooc to scale i think is community
support
right so that's one thing that i talked
about like the forums like the
assignments like
people who are engaged like you know
helping each other out like correcting
mistakes in my content adding stuff to
my content
um not i paid for this course like
where's my like ta office hour where's
my like you know why isn't the
you know professor responded and my
thing's been up two hours because i paid
like
x dollars for this course kind of like
takes all the
the bad parts of teaching and like
injects them back in
um uh and then i think basically
you know there are various things that
can kind of dilute the support right
so i think students like when they pay
and expect staff
you know staff content this sense of
entitlement seems to really like dilute
dilute this sort of spirit of support um
students who are basically not
interested in that
you know and that content like i think
there are a lot of like
seems like everyone who's taken the sdn
course i teach really wants to be there
right if they're not they just drop out
the others may not care actually they
make they're just there for an online
masters in cs and like
okay i gotta take this networking thing
hugely different
and then i think the other thing that i
alluded to that i'll just briefly
mention here is that
this go at your own pace style so when i
offered the course i've actually
convinced them to change this right
when i offered the online masters
networking course the first time
they basically just open the floodgates
to all the material and you know
within two hours there were people like
oh homework eight like i don't
understand like what's going on and i'm
like
what's happening here like i mean i've
got ta so now you've got this
like perfect storm of like students who
are paying expecting like rapid feedback
and engagement from a course staff
who's now gonna figure like get their
head into eight different assignments at
once
just like didn't work at all um so i
think
um you know a lot of those things some
of them may be fundamental some of them
i think
you know obviously that last one can be
fixed and i you know i i
i did change that um then i think
there are other platform specific
factors that prevent scaling and i think
like
important you know as i mentioned sort
of like the studio the content creation
type of things
the importance of like giving the
instructor autonomy um
in creation and also visibility over
what they're doing is really important i
would say that
um you know again to kind of like be
provocative here
i don't actually get paid to teach the
coursera course
and the tas don't either right i
basically just did it because i was like
oh mooks hype let's see what's going on
like i want to
sort of contribute to this dialogue with
with some experience
and then it turned out that it had a
bunch of ancillary benefits like
to my own research and other things that
i didn't expect it's been a hugely
positive experience
the other course actually this one is
lucrative for me like i actually make
money
teaching this course and i actually get
much less joy out of it so
um so i think there's something to be
learned there um
so just in conclusion and then to sort
of open it up for a discussion
to make these moocs scalable they
require community engagement
low barriers to creating content and
also like supporting a diversity of
delivery modes to mat
you know that's suitable for delivering
the material and
and certainly not all platforms are easy
are equal
and i think the other thing that sort of
i've realized is that
you know there are all different flavors
of moocs and a four credit
mooc you know as part of a degree
program is just like
vastly different you know than a you
know free
mooc on a very highly specialized topic
kind of
obvious once you sort of state it but
just a lot of things came up there that
i didn't expect
and that i tried to share with you so i
guess we have like half an hour for a
discussion
oh the microphone yeah so i guess like
this is being recorded so i've been
asked to uh
uh tell people that and tell people to
speak into the microphone
yes one thing we've found uh on staff
recording their their own videos uh that
i just wondered if you've met the same
thing is that uh
it's often really good to go back and
re-record your first one
yeah yeah because you improve so much
after you've done a few
i've done that actually so um uh
i mean that's another thing too is that
like um you know
pluses and minuses with do it yourself
sometimes the software like doesn't work
right and i've actually recorded i've
recorded a take of a video only to have
the software crash
right it wouldn't happen in a studio but
um then
i'm forced to do it again i'm like oh
that was way better so
um and what i haven't done
but i plan to do either in the next
offering or the offering after that is
to re-record all the videos
actually um so yeah
um this has been great by the way and
just uh
this is more of a comment than a
question but i've been to at least a
couple of other sessions now where
people have brought up repeatedly the
idea of well is this going to be
sustainable if faculty members aren't
getting
reasonably compensated for their time
yeah it would be very interesting for a
lot of
you should find a way to tweet a version
of what you said that you know on the
one hand here is this free course
that was a lot of work but it was fun i
didn't make any money but it impacted
my teaching and my research in positive
ways i didn't anticipate which by the
way
amen i say all the same things yeah on
the other hand here's this quite
lucrative course
that i think your own words were was a
lot less joy yep to be involved with
i don't know anybody who is in the
profession that we're in for things
other than joy
or some approximation of it it's
certainly not for money exactly so it
might be interesting for you to get that
out there as anyway that's all yeah i
know i i definitely uh i'll figure out a
way to get that out there
um yeah
so thanks i thought this was quite
helpful i'm also a professor of computer
science and so i think
i'm hoping that other people sort of
absorb some of the things that you said
because there were some technical
details in there that i think that were
kind of important but
um one thing i've sort of wondered what
i've seen with these new platforms is
they sort of remind me of old online
portals right i mean they're trying to
do a lot of things
they're trying to do a lot of things
that are done well by sort of point
solutions in other places right so the
bulletin board is a great example right
i mean piazza runs a forum right
i mean piazza has a few other dicky
features where you can like upload your
syllabus and stuff like that right
but they're not pretending to be a mooc
they're just running a forum right it's
a pretty good forum
there are things about it i don't like
right but i haven't tried using either
coursera or edx with these tools but i
i'm sort of worried that again it's back
to the sort of portal model right where
there's this like one home page i'm
going to go to
yahoo and it's going to have all my
email and weather and everything else
and
the internet hasn't gone in that
direction right i mean we have
specialized solutions for these things
we expect people to navigate
bring in like things from different
places also for video right i mean i
have to say i mean
i'm surprised i get really frustrated
with my colleagues who can't get a video
on youtube
right i mean this is something that a
six-year-old with a smartphone can do
right yeah and we hit people we pretend
i mean even here right like we need this
you know forty thousand dollar recording
uh rig and a professional sitting back
there turning it around
you know in order to get a get a you
know and you know
sorry about that but i mean but you know
i have a smartphone in my pocket that
can solve this problem right
so and and yeah it's not going to be as
high quality but there's also i think
some evidence from other studies that
the quality doesn't matter right exactly
what you discovered
right yeah i mean the production values
of the video aren't really what matters
yeah i mean my comment there isn't
scientific i'd love to see like uh you
know
like people who are here like do
something about that because
i mean just in like anecdotally like
it just doesn't matter like oh okay it's
a little clipped right there or
something
oh it has okay perfect okay yeah i'd
love to see that paper
what was there that uh once you get
above a certain threat as long as the
speaker is an interesting person and the
video is intelligible
above that threshold engagement does not
seem to be a function of production
quality
but again think about you right i mean
people watch all sorts of things
parallel production dogs but if there's
a cat in it right right
yeah i'll start putting cats
yeah okay so i'm going to argue with you
guys on that a little bit
so i'm the creative director for
innovative education at university of
south florida and basically
i run the video multimedia group who
does all that stuff
yeah yeah and i think i don't think it's
about platforms not being equal i think
speaking from a video perspective if
your goal is to do
exactly what you're doing certainly a
video team can work with you and say
instead of coming into the studio and
making you work off of a tablet
maybe we can come into your office and
shoot it and maybe have a little bit
higher quality
and offer you opportunities that you
don't have when you're shooting it
yourself
so you know i think it would be awesome
splicing some interviews that you have
with people
use the equipment that your video team
has to
be able to do that yeah i think that's
that's certainly
like it kind of goes in line a little
bit with what i'm saying which is like
basically what you're saying is like
work with the instructor right to kind
of like
work within their mode right i think
what it sort of breaks down is it's like
you must come here and like work within
our mode and i'm like no this is just is
not happening
you know yeah yeah
instead of you having to edit all that
stuff or retake and redo all this stuff
if you had
a service that could do that that was
assisting you
then maybe that would be better yeah and
that would be a service
if every faculty member institutions
there's no way you guys will be able to
provide that service right
and that's like we get that right i mean
it's and this is what
faculty will say is they say well i
tried to videotape my class but i
contacted them and they're all busy
and they can't set their dedicated rig
and this stuff's expensive right i'm
saying there's cheaper solutions
that scale better we're talking about
scalability you know maybe it has a
place to start
yeah yeah i mean that was sort of one
thing that kind of like got me off into
the just uh
the do-it-yourself mode is like the
studio time was booked right and
and this was even like two years ago
when people were like what
was and what are moocs you know um and
even then i couldn't get
studio time so yeah it was at that point
where i was like okay i'm just gonna
like do it myself so
yeah there are certain things where the
scaling
uh does definitely come into play the
i just want to agree with what you just
said that there is no tyranny of the
media team
i think the most of the teams that i
know are very very accommodating
and if you as a faculty member want to
do it on your own
go ahead and do it on your own yeah and
i think there are a number of best
practices that you can get from the
media team that would help your camtasia
be even better
um but i think we're creating a
statement that i don't know maybe that's
the case at georgia tech that you have
to do things a certain way but i don't
that seems to be the exception rather
than the rule i think most media teams
are very
accommodating as to how you want to do
things and provide more consulting
than than anything if necessary i think
the consulting services that you
mentioned would be
would be highly valuable i mean like to
your point in the back like
that you know there's there's certainly
a lot of interest in terms of like this
sort of do-it-yourself mode but
but also like yeah i don't know what i'm
doing like you know it took me a while
to figure out like how to even look at
the camera and like you know
have people say like you know stop
telling me i look stoned because i was
like looking down
like you know during an interview right
so yeah i mean like
just these basic things and i did have
someone like from that office like watch
some of my
you know some of my initial videos but
yeah you're completely right i mean
you know something that could scale as a
consulting service to help people like
to be better at production yeah so
yeah okay
so i mean i don't think if i heard your
talk correctly i don't think that
i don't think i heard you saying that uh
that it's not a good idea to have
production and videography and whatever
team's around and available to help
i think what i heard you say is the way
that the organization the production
went
does not match the way that faculty
typically put together their courses
where there's
some amount of justin timeism and
there's adjusting after the fact and
yeah and
and we had a very similar experience a
thing that has worked pretty well at
berkeley
is uh for faculty who have not done this
before the first time they do one of
these courses
they will go in with the the production
videography team for like their first
couple of recording sessions
they'll get a lot of pointers how to do
things how not to do things the kind of
stuff you're talking about and then
after that
typically they'll say thank you i get it
i will now record and because we have a
couple of little studios set up that are
essentially self-service
we can still take advantage of the
production team for doing edits or
things that are more complicated but
after
they've gotten the hang of it with
professional coaching they're in a much
better place and they actually don't
want
to be in a studio with somebody hanging
over the whole time what they want is to
do it on their own time as the course
goes along
so i think there is a happy medium and i
think there's a great use of that
resource
but what i think i heard you say was
this you know let's do everything up
front with a script and now we're done
that's it's difficult for faculty to get
used to preparing a course that way
yeah think it's i don't even think it's
like possible to do it
in as high quality if you're doing it
that way
you said that not me but yeah but i
think i think you're talking about the
process more than the absolutely the
actual
team or equipment or anything like that
yeah no definitely
uh also audio uh microphones you know
the
near field uh headset uh microphones now
you can
use them pretty much anywhere except
with a dump truck
unloading next to you and you get
absolutely fantastic audio
even with background noises and so forth
so
and the resolution of your camtasia
screen capture
videos is exactly the same as what you
get in the studio
there's no difference yeah so i think
you've had your hand up for quite a
while yeah
what i also wonder about is how useful
video is at all everyone says oh we have
to have video we have to have video but
some of that's an artifact just from the
era of the monasteries when we
stood up in front of the all the other
abbots and
read out the bible but the transferable
skill for
students is probably reading books
there's thousands or hundreds of
thousands of more books than sets of
videos
and i think we de-emphasize that a lot
in the mooc teaching because we're just
trying to transfer
a regular course onto a mooc and we
actually have a chance now to change how
we teach
yeah the mode is very interesting like
and i i haven't quite figured out myself
right because like
in the classroom i don't use slides like
i use you know i just use the board and
i lecture off notes and then i was like
doing this mooc and i'm like slides like
what's this
this is not going to be great i mean it
was fine
and then in the other course when i was
basically scribbling on a tablet
i was like well this should be better
because it's kind of like whiteboard
right and it sucks
actually it's like you know it's all
messy i don't like it's like
really doesn't look good and then when
when they're like ah
it's like a little close to the margin
can you redo this and i'm like no i'm
not gonna redo
45 minutes of me like scribbling out
proofs like because it's two inches like
too close to the margin so
but why not put proofs in a book and
have a book
i mean yeah i mean this is crazy well
but i guess like i mean yeah but before
we get off on that tangent like i guess
the point i was trying to make was like
the way that i was delivering stuff by
video was like totally like i thought
basically slides would not be you know
of course writing's better because that
seems to work better in the classroom
and for me it was exactly the opposite
so anyway
yeah and i just want to say there
there's a difference between
presenting a proof is a great example
but it's like a program or anything else
it's a feta complete
and in a book it's a feta complete and
it's right there and there's something
fundamentally different
about the thought process of going
through it
and articulating the process and
revealing you know i
let me say i'm not arguing for revealing
but but you're not just it's not dead
silence and i'm now just writing it what
happens is i'm writing it and i'm
talking to you
and there's there's this implicit
message of
where the hard parts are that gets sort
of conveyed
by your body language and your timing
and everything
right i don't want else i want to see it
step by step right because you can write
that out in the book too you can say
well
here's this overall structure here's the
heart parts here's the
pokey now he managed to do this part
here's where we fill that left well it
happens this is an interesting point
like time
in my editing of course like i edit out
things you know where i
where i have to stop and think right or
i
if like of course mistakes i'll edit out
right so like those things get edited
out so
there is like the video is sort of
somewhere in between the book and the
live lecture really interesting to
actually if you're doing this in a free
move
to actually run an ap test
my hypothesis which i would love to see
you test is that it is actually better
to reveal the stopping and thinking
and the most even not almost like stupid
mistakes no but but the ones that
they're likely to make yeah actually
exposing to the
my own students report that you know
when that happens that's actually
incredibly useful
one of the things i did like i this it
would be interesting to put it into the
videos but one of the things i did was
like
when i did one of the programming
assignments i actually made some
mistakes
and in the quizzes basically i i
basically
put my buggy code and i was like okay
here's a mistake i made like what's
wrong with this so
it's not quite the same but it's
yeah i just want to say one of the i'm
beth from edx
um one a professor shared with me sort
of a
something that was a bit of a revelation
maybe shouldn't have been about
why he uses videos and what the
intention is for him and how he
feels about them and why he doesn't mind
having low production
value he said i don't think of the video
as
anything that replicates any other
teaching moment that i have where i'm
addressing an entire classroom full of
students
what i think of the video as is my
near approximation of what it's like to
have a student
sitting next to me at my shoulder asking
me questions about
a topic so for him the
teaching moment is on that sort of
one-to-one
and it's and he thinks of it as like the
only
i mean one of the true advantages of
moocs is that you can sort of treat
that like your opportunity to have that
possible moment
with thousands of people and not just
the 10 that can make office hours with
you and so when he
thought of it that way when he sort of
changed his mental state from think it
was a replacement for the lecture
replacement for the book
or something like that or a redaction
section
as a moment to have that one-to-one you
know opportunities within
the students then he really changed his
thinking about yeah it's an interesting
thing i mean we're saying like why do we
need videos and
and like actually it's another thing i'd
be curious i don't have again any like
sort of scientific data about this but
like in the coursera course there is
like a headshot of me
like speaking on the slides you know
like many moocs and the other one it's
basically a hand and like one of the
things
uh he's scribbling right so one of the
things people have said to me
who've taken the course central course
some of them i've like you know chatted
to on the phone later met in person and
they're like
boy i feel like i know you already you
know and they're like i get that a lot
um but no one's ever said that to me
like in the other court and i don't know
if it's just like
there's obviously not a controlled
experiment there but it's
yeah nice hand hey you're married huh
you can see the wedding ring
yeah exactly i've got
a couple of remarks i'm william
vogenberg of delft university of
technology
the first thing is
that now i forgot my point um
first of all what i notice in your story
is is that
um you hardly got any support from your
institution and and they're doing more
moocs and more things so i've i would
have thought that
you would share they would share that
experience and know a little bit
what can help you and and that surprises
me
um and i i can understand that
you want to do more yourself but that's
that's the way to organize it
at least for us we say we d we you do it
yourself
we do it with you or we do it for you
and you can choose what you want
we are there for the teachers to help
them and it's their choice on
how to do that so you can do everything
in the studio
or you we give you a camera and you do
it yourself
the other thing uh what we notice is
that
we try to convince teachers that they
spend more time in preparation of the
of making the video instead of
doing a lot of post-production with the
preparation
before the video take you increase the
quality
with post-production you can never
increase the quality of the video
so spending more time in the preparation
really increases the video and i know
that is very hard for teachers that
instead of
recording preparing their lectures the
night before they have
lecture they now have to do that more in
advance and that's
something they have to get used to but
eventually
what we noticed is that it really
improves the quality and that
they will notice that and they now use
the videos also for their regular
classes and
not only for the moocs
so one thing that's interesting is uh if
you go to a
good lecture in a large classroom
there's a certain amount of energy
that that you get from the students and
and it gets reflected back
by the faculty and and that and
even the moocs that have used large
recorded
lectures basically in a classroom you
see when you look at that there's this
certain set of energy
how do you keep that energy
in when you're recording by yourself in
your bedroom
i don't know red bull
i i i don't know yeah i i guess do you
feel like it is a difference i mean like
if you're in front of 100 students
i don't know i don't know if that's the
right question like uh i mean like i
mean
i guess coming back to the comment that
was made before like
maybe maybe recreating that energy of a
lecture hall isn't
isn't going to happen in the video maybe
it's not supposed to one of the things i
see is like there's energy in the forums
or there's not energy in the forums
right so i
do make a concerted effort in the forums
to stay and that's where i think the
platforms and your point about like
uh the earlier point about like why are
people rolling their own forums because
like people kind of like know how to do
good
i mean i couldn't actually keep the
energy high in the coursera forums but
like using piazza it was much easier
because it was like
okay i mean many of us in here have used
piazza so we know like it doesn't take
that much to go in there babysit it like
give it a few shots in the arm and
actually like there's a lot going on
so i think yeah the energy in the videos
i don't know maybe people some people
have cats and other things but like
i don't actually try i don't try to keep
the energy high in the videos but the
forms i
actually where things are not in the
videos i try to basically put more
energy into the forums and i think it's
possible to do it there
i just want to make a quick follow-up so
i think it's a really personal thing
about the energy
i have a colleague who is so engaging
on film she is unbelievable you are
convinced she is speaking to you
and only you when you watch these videos
she's
she's incredible and so i think you can
keep that energy up but i think it's a
really personal thing like i've seen her
videos and been
absolutely astonished um and she
is you know an incredibly distinguished
person
but she doesn't take herself too
seriously so she added a video where she
says
we're gonna now do a stretching break
and so this you know distinguished
harvard business school professor gets
up
and leads their students through
stretches in the middle of her mooc
she's unbelievable so i think you can do
it but it's a real skill
yeah i do not have the skill yeah that
seems like a
super specialized skill and yeah i would
say for me like
i mean and this is another thing where
like in the
in the sdn course like because it's such
a niche topic and something where it's
like actually pretty close to my
research
i'm super interested in it myself so
it's not hard for me to like fake energy
and a lot of times a lot of times i'm
like actually learning it
as you know not quite as i give the
lecture right obviously but like
you know almost in conjunction
conjunction with teaching the course so
like
i'm very much into it myself whereas i
think if you're just sort of like
lecturing on a general networking topic
can be
maybe we need stretching breaks actually
um so i'm a sociologist but i came into
this
talk sort of expecting as i
as i understand expecting a more
technical discussion
of the differences between the platforms
uh but when i came and when
your story was very interesting but as i
as i listened to it i realized that
it could be sort of what you are
describing is a set of
institutional issues that you ran into
in coursera and in udacity and both of
sort of
i mean if i was an economist i would say
you had two different incentives but i
want to get it
but uh i was wondering the one
part where you said you had where i
could see a sort of technical issue
was in your autograders so i was
wondering if your
difficulty not being able to make an
autograder for the udacity class your
was was an institutional issue in the
sense that you did not have the labor to
make it
or was it a technical issue in the sense
that it was difficult for you to do it
both i think basically it's and could
you start it and it starts off as a
technical
it starts off as a technical issue oh
there's no auto grading servers to
basically you know oh we can't submit
like output and have them basically
graded at scale but
do that with scripts but then basically
what we get into is like okay we don't
design the assignment so that they
they can be auto graded now we get into
a self-perpetuating thing it becomes
institutionalized which is like
we have a ton of assignments can't be
auto graded
now we've got paid tas right so this
gets into the whole like institution
thing it's like
people are kind of like getting fat off
the you know the online masters like
people getting
no incentive to basically streamline it
right
like publishers like governments
there's no incentive to streamline it so
i i just started off technical but
it quickly becomes institutional yeah
okay
yeah i understand it because i've
experienced this yeah
okay the the most pronounced immediate
effect after putting together all the
mooc materials
is that the injection of those materials
back into the campus class especially
all of the auto grading and automation
and streamlining and the virtual machine
had such an amazingly positive effect on
the campus class
yes that it changed the way we think
about fixing the campus class we no
longer do something for the campus class
that cannot be scaled
the only exception to that is that we
have this very
intensive group project that is an
essential part of the campus class and
by the way is totally absent in the mooc
version
but what it means for the campus is the
tas can spend roughly 100 of their time
on that
instead of all of the things that have
been automated away yeah it's changed
the way that we think about developing
course materials
and definitely for the better because
the students don't learn that much
synthesis from doing the homework
because they get basic skill building
the synthesis is learned from doing
open-ended projects that's the hard part
right
we haven't figured out any good way to
scale that with with
you know fewer instructors than we have
so instead we're trying to scale
everything else so that we can devote
more
relatively more resources to that piece
and that's a conversion that i did not
expect but it's made
it's like night and day yeah this is
huge i mean like we're we're
i mean
no i'm i'm i'm completely on the same
wavelength here with armando as far as
like
when we made the auto grading work for
the coursera course it's exactly what
he's saying like
basically i teach that course on campus
and one of the things that like when you
teach it to
tens of thousands of people you
streamline stuff and you operationalize
things and you figure out how to
automate things that ca
that can be automated right and you get
organized
and that level of streamlining and
organization
leaves you time to basically do other
things like the tas are basically oh
they're actually teaching because
they're not
spending all this time like you know
doing technical support for someone
who's basically installed something on a
version of ubuntu that's like three
years old
it's like no all that stuff is gone and
they can instead like basically focus on
the stuff that
you know that hopefully matters more so